-Yeah, it's so great
to see you guys.
Come on. Hello.
-Hi, Jimmy.
-You're here on a perfect day.
It is Global James Bond Day.
And you both wrote and recorded
the theme song,
which is awesome.
I love it.
I want to know everything.
I want to know
how it all came together.
I want to know every single --
just go for like two hours.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, it was a crazy,
surreal experience.
I don't remember
when it all kind of...
-Started.
-...was real.
But I do know that
for many years
we've wanted to
write a Bond song.
Not even like we
thought we could.
It was just more like...
-A fantasy.
-...a fantasy,
like a complete fantasy.
Like, how cool would it be
to do this, you know?
But I think it was
last summer-ish.
It started being a topic of
discussion and not a fantasy,
and it was very insane to us.
Yeah, it was --
it was a couple months of
very, like, disbelief, I think.
-Were there scraps of songs
that you tried and you're like,
"I think I got it.
This is 'No Time to Die.'"
And you're like...
♪ No time to die ♪
♪ Da-ba-bup, ba-ba-bup,
no time to die, ooh ♪
And then, you go,
"Okay, let me just come back --
Let's do this tomorrow."
Or did you know immediately,
like, "Oh, this is the tune"?
-You know, what's funny is
that we kind of started
with making sure we got,
like, a melody that we felt
was really solid before we tried
any lyrics out.
But we did definitely, you know,
before we had written anything,
go like, I -- we both think
it's really important to have
the title of the movie
in the song
and have the song be called that
because it just --
it wouldn't have been satisfying
otherwise, and so --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Like, thinking how would
we make that make sense?
What could we say?
What could we -- Whatever.
So it was kind of -- we were
kind of stuck for like a few --
the first few days
we tried to work on it.
We were, like, you know --
It was a lot of pressure.
It's a [bleep] Bond song.
It's like, what are you supposed
to -- So we were pretty stumped,
and then there was just one day
where Finneas was playing on
the piano, and he just played
this one melody,
and it was just that...
♪ Da-da-da ♪
And we were just like....
-"Yes!"
It's like, dude,
it's so perfect.
You go -- Because they all
have that, like, mysterious --
They have, like, a mystique
to the Bond themes.
It was like...
-Yeah.
-It's like...
♪ Da-da-da, da ♪
It's weird progression,
but then you got that --
Oh, and it's almost
like that one --
I don't even know
what chord it is.
But it's like that...
♪ Rrrnggg ♪
-Yeah.
-You know, with
the jangly guitar.
And you're like, "Ah."
I don't know.
Did they like it as soon as
you sent it to them?
Did they have notes?
-Hans Zimmer loved it.
I know that.
He was the one, I know that --
He really connected to it,
which was crazy for us.
-Hans Zimmer?
-Yeah, I know.
-The greatest.
-How was that whole thing?
-It was crazy!
It was -- He is a doll.
He is such a joy.
And his main thing was that he
wanted us to just see the movie
before we --
like, just so that we knew.
So we flew out to London,
and we watched the movie,
which was, you know,
like a rough cut, I guess,
a year ago-ish,
under a year ago.
And then we worked with him
for like a week-ish.
-Had an orchestra.
It was really cool.
-It was really amazing.
-[ Laughs ]
-He's so cool.
-Yeah.
-I mean, how fun is that?
How does it work with
an orchestra?
Like, can you change things
or they just kind of know
what's already written and they
go, "We're just doing this"?
-Dude, that's a good question,
and I would have thought that
you couldn't change stuff once
it was written, but all day,
Hans, Stephen Lipson,
who also helped
produced the song with us,
and we would lean in
and we'd go like,
"Could we have them try
something a little bit spookier
here?"
And they would go to the
orchestra and say, "Do this."
And they would change
in real time.
-It was crazy.
-Like, all 70 people.
Everyone was so good.
It was incredible.
-That's pretty cool.
You both did a virtual
performance at the DNC.
I think it was "My Future,"
and it was great.
Everyone looked -- People were
like, "This was so good."
And before you performed,
Billie, you spoke.
Why was that important to you?
-To be honest, I just think
it was my responsibility
to do that.
I really couldn't want to be
involved in politics less.
I would literally rather do
anything else
than be talking about this
and be doing anything.
And I just think
that that's not...
I think that should show you
how much this actually
means right now
because even with me,
who is somebody that, like,
I used to just, you know,
completely shut up.
I don't want to talk about it.
I don't want to deal with it.
I don't want to
hear anybody's opinions.
give my own opinions.
You know, I don't want to
deal with it.
I don't want to think about it.
There just comes a certain point
where, like,
you can't just --
-Ignore it.
-Yeah, you can't ignore it.
You can't be silent.
And I think it's -- especially
having the platform that I have,
I don't want to waste that.
So I think it's really important
that we all talk and speak up
even if we'd rather die.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-You know?
-I think it was really cool
that you did that.
Finneas, last time you were
on the show, we talked about
how you and Billie work everyday
sounds into your songs.
You actually played me, like, a
crosswalk beeping or something.
It was so --
It was mind-blowing.
I was wondering
if you wouldn't mind showing us
how you do some of it.
-Absolutely.
So, thank you
for segueing into this.
And thank you also for being
generous enough to send me
your four recordings
that you sent.
Just for the audience, I'm going
to play a couple of them.
This is my personal
favorite one.
♪ -Jimmy Bond ♪
-I like that one a lot.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh. Jimmy Bond.
-I like Jimmy Bond a lot.
-Please don't laugh at me.
Please. Jimmy Bond.
-Yeah, that one's great.
♪ -Vote ♪
-You singing "vote" is great.
[ Laughter ]
-I figured why not.
-This one -- This one is great.
♪ -Shakin' ♪
-You singing "shakin'" is great.
-Oh, "shakin'", yeah.
I thought that could be the name
of our song, our Bond song.
-It's great.
That should be the name of it.
-[ Laughing ] "Shakin'".
-And then you sent me this file
of you singing, which is great.
♪ -Time to die ♪
♪ No time ♪
♪ No time to die ♪
-Which is awesome.
♪ -No time ♪
-I wish we'd had that
when we first started...
-Making the real song.
-...writing the song
because that would've
been great.
So I'm going to try to make,
if it's okay with you...
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm gonna try to make a beat
really quickly out of
the samples you sent me.
Does that sound okay?
-I'm freaking out right now.
Everything is falling off.
I'm freaking out right now.
-Okay, so, here.
-Start with Jimmy Bond.
-Jimmy Bond.
♪ -Jimmy Bond ♪
-I'm going to pitch it down.
♪ -Jimmy, Jimmy,
Jimmy, Jimmy Bond ♪
-Very cool, very metal.
♪ -Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond, Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy, Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
-Yeah!
♪ -Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
-Give him a little beat.
Give him a little beat.
♪ -Jimmy, Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond, Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy, Jimmy Bond ♪
-[ Laughs ]
♪ -Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond, Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy, Jimmy Bond ♪
I love it.
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ To die ♪
♪ No time ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy, Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ No time ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ To die ♪
♪ No time ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy, Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ No time ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ To die ♪
♪ No time ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy, Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ No time ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ To die ♪
♪ No time ♪
-That's too fun.
♪ -Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy, Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ No time ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ To die ♪
♪ No time ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy, Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ No time ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ To die ♪
♪ No time ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ Jimmy, Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ No time ♪
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
♪ To die ♪
♪ No time ♪
You are a genius!
♪ Jimmy Bond ♪
You are brilliant!
You are brilliant. Oh, my gosh.
That is what I'm talking about.
Two of the most talented people
out there.
Thank you guys so much.